casey is coming up a very strong outing
in boston up against one of the best
lineups in all of major league baseball
so that's got to be a nice confidence
boost for him and hopefully kate takes
that same mentality in tonight's
ballgame and gets a little revenge
against the royals well you've got a guy
there good speed in merrifield and here
is a good hitter in salvador perez who's
always done well against detroit and the
first pitch is a slider and salvi goes
after it and slices it in the gap and
that will drop in comes merrifield
santana around the third
and salvador perez has himself a double
and it's one nothing royals
salvi must have thought maybe he might
not start me with the fastball he threw
a little wrinkle and savvy from here it
looked like it was off the end of the
bat but man look at that 87 on the outer
half of the plate and down and now jorge
soler
and he's after the first pitch
santana is the runner at third and
mazzara makes the play
santana will hold
the royals want to get that second run
home they've taken a one-nothing lead on
a hit batter a walk a double they've
made mize pay for his mistake and
runners at second and third with one out
and ben and tendy hits it hard to left
field that will be caught
santana will tag and come down the line
and will make it two-nothing royals on
ben and tindy's sacrifice fly
and the royals have scored nine runs in
their last three innings
perez at second big pitch three two
swinging a miss fastball got him
and the tigers will be facing danny
duffy who has a 1.26 era
in his first six starts
yeah beautiful just 10 walks 40
strikeouts he's getting after it his
focus is extreme this is one of the best
starts in royals history for a starting
pitcher through his first six starts
grossman likely
to be swinging and he does and goes to
right field
but there is jorge solaire right at the
warning track to pull it down for out
number one that's a dangerous part of
that ballpark
inside out swing and solaire will play
it on a bounce he might have had a
sliver of sunlight in his eyes
the southpaw delivers ground ball too
short they go second one first base
two a double play
a late call by first base empire edwin
moscoso but it results in two outs and
we head to the second inning of play
with the royals leading the tigers
to nothing tigers have runners at the
corners now for jacoby jones on 2-2
the other way a base hit for jacoby
jones tigers are on the board mazzara is
going to chug for third he will cruise
in there
the rbi single from jacoby jones makes
it 2-1 royals
jacoby jones making some really good
adjustments at the plate over in fenway
boston was pitching him in and he
recognized that and was turning on him
this at-bat right here danny duffy was
keeping everything away from him and
jacoby jones recognized that and said
okay you're going to shift me over there
i'm going to go with that pitch and hit
it to the right side so good piece of
hitting by jacoby jones to identify what
they were game planning to do against
him
right down the heart of the plate strike
three called that does it for detroit
they get a run on one hit with the
royals leading 2-1 scope single
candelario walked with one away tigers
down a run to kansas city here in the
third cabrera zero extra base hits his
last ten games the one two a bullet to
left that's a base hit and jonathan
scope is gonna score and the tigers have
tied it at two thanks to miguel
cabrera's rbi single here in the third
passes mellott ties omar viscoe number
43 all time in major league hits they've
been some hard hit outs
but maize has set down 14 of the last 15
so the royals are without a hit or a
base runner since the second the 3-2
swinging to miss he got him with the
fastball casey mize is rolling he was he
was tardy on that heater wasn't he
fourth strikeout
ends the fifth he's retired 10 in a row
3-1 on robbie grossman
swings away down the right field line
that ball is going to be fair into the
corner and off the wall grossman will
dig for third
and he will
get there with a pop-up slide
triple last night
a triple tonight and it kick-starts the
tigers fifth now candelario who's hit
into a double play and walked candelario
drives one to deep center
dyson going back that's over his head
and up against the wall candelario digs
for second has himself an rbi double the
tigers have their first lead of the
night chamber likes that first pitch
hunting hunting fastball he gets a
little slider up and out over the plate
what a good swing jumped all over that
first pitch and did not miss it tyson
plays a very shallow center field had no
chance to get it and here's miguel
cabrera swinging a line drive base hit
into shallow right field pass to diving
merrifield candelario around third he
will score without a throw
merrifield was shaded up the middle the
ball went
just to his left as he dove another rbi
for miguel cabrera and the tigers take a
4-2 lead in the fifth yes sir didn't hit
it hard but hit it in the right spot and
now miguel cabrera honored no
venezuelan-born player has ever had more
hits in a major league career than that
man right there
there it is
deadens it rogers a howitzer to first
dyson can scoot but he doesn't outrun
jake rogers fastball to first base you
talk about pouncing on a ball
how about that jimmy boy that's quick
feed right there catchers love that play
2-1 to scope
slowly to third
no play jonathan scope is aboard
on his third base hit of the night
yeah way back at third base and jonathan
scope you know sometimes it's better to
be lucky than good but you'll take the
2-2 pitch swinging the ground ball hit
hard to third down to a knee to grab it
as candelario across the diamond to
cabrera another strong accurate throw
the hit batter does no harm
field stranded at first we head to the
bottom of the eighth inning in detroit
the tigers hold on to a 4-2 lead over
the royals gregory soto is a guy who is
working in his 17th game this year has
thrown 14 and two-thirds innings given
up 16 hits
11 walks though solera board the leadoff
man on there's andrew benintendi the 1-1
to benintendi turns on one to right
mazara had him positioned perfectly and
there's one away the 2-0
fly ball center field
jacoby jones has got it and the tigers
win again
4-2 the final over the royals
casey mize gives up two early and then
rolls to the next five innings tigers
offense comes alive against danny duffy
with some big runs after the two-nothing
deficit